[Music]
I'm Jose Coto Tom Jose jr. we are 188
very quickly frito in the Bronx coochi
frito is the fast food restaurant for
Puerto Rican people where they can get
all kinds of fried items who shoot free
throws is basically every part of the
pig fried comes from everywhere a little
bit of Dominican a little Puerto Rican
and a little Cuban and everything
when Anthony Bourdain came here on
parson own it was honestly a great
feeling he gave us the title of you know
the center of the pork universe in New
York and since he came we have gotten
like a whole different array of people
we've gotten people from different
states from California to Texas Canada
we got people from Japan India they come
and they tell us they want whatever
Anthony Bourdain has they night and it's
important for a place like this to exist
because we go back to the roots of being
you know Latino it's not like many other
places where they trying to do this new
fusion cuisine where they mix two three
cultures together we stick to what we
know and what we're good at
[Music]
sheesh at home is buy pork skin it's
basically pork rinds it's two types of
chicharrón one has me and one has only
skin so the one with the skin is mostly
the one we use for the mofongo now the
one with the meat on it is for the
column of red belly in English oh Panza
de cerdo and panel so we pre cooking
once it's pretty cool
bring it out we seasoned it and we let
them sit down fresh for about 24 hours
and after that we fry as a demand to fry
the chicken we use pork lard because
it's all basically in the same product
we cook the chicharrón for about 40
minutes before we bring it to the front
to serve other people mofongo is green
plantain is mash with a garlic sauce and
pork rind which are on any food you eat
or you go to this day serve mofongo the
way we make our own the phone 101 88
could you frito we make we not worst off
right from the scratch fresh we get a
green flattened as we slice it out so
that it cooks evenly once it's cooked we
put with the garlic sauce and we mash
and we make sure that every little piece
of Latin others there's well cook
normally we marcharon epilogue that's a
word pad with a piece of wood and then
we put the chicharrón with myself it
into red and they were involved it and
servers on the play
the way we'll make our point free Thalia
chickens were getting from the local
butcher shops around we season it with
salt pepper and garlic we fry the
chicken normally from between 30 and 45
minutes depends on the amount of chicken
that we put in the pot we're now using
deep fryers we're using big drums filled
with soybean oil this is the old school
way of doing it before there was deep
fryers and all of that we look in the be
tender moister and fresh be at the same
time that golden brown color and this is
something that we use is different you
know a lot of people took K and hot
sauce sugar on it
we don't use none of those pearl when
you just fry water based on cooking
products trying to keep it back to the
original roots of the food the Bronx has
been changing everything years back from
the 60s to the 80s you have a big
community of Puerto Rican then in the
eighties to start coming in Dominicans
and then after the nineties you start
getting our South American peoples of
Mexico and today we have a big mix of
Spanish people from whole central South
America and the Caribbean
I mean honestly we still have some of
the same customers who come out here
since I was 8 10 years old they still
coming here they still walking through
the door you try to show me another
restaurant that still has hand-painted
signs in it we've been here forever and
I plan on staying here forever
here we are 188 Street and Grand
Concourse in the Bronx New York where I
grew up
we've been here my whole life my father
started this business 30 40 years ago
and we've been here ever since
everybody else has been out here for
almost as long - yeah we got the candy
store here for you maybe 40 years it's a
tight-knit community definitely
everybody out here knows each other and
you know they look out for each other
now we're all Grand Concourse around the
corner from the restaurant cops
everywhere that business I can remember
is this is this is what it is just look
around I was here before he was born
we just don't the break it is down below
yeah and my father and my uncles I used
to wonder bakery there and I used to
come around here when I was a kid here
we are for the Fordham fried chicken and
seafood across the street from our
restaurant and they've probably been
here before for us yeah maybe even
longer than us on this block franchises
are taking over they're coming around
and they're buying all the property and
taking over you know the I increase and
friend want to force every small
business to get out of business so how
long you been here was about 32 years
see it's 32 years and 36 years he used
to be down try and move you here that's
what's happening the business in the
branch grants the increases and you have
to believe
[Music]
back in 1961 my father left Cuba and
came into the night of stay we stay in
Miami Florida for a couple months
then we localized here in New York when
my uncle's used to leave and they don't
want that introduce my father into the
business at that time I was 20 years old
we stopped cooking Puerto Rican food at
that time because mostly all out kill
youtell was fo Ricans and I let the tray
and continue with it through the ages
they all been disappearing and I'm
probably one of the oldest family that
stay around my father's been doing this
my whole life
this is this is all I know of him his
work work work and just you know
dedication to what he does and what he
enjoys and I think it's great that he's
getting all this recognition after all
these years of doing it he's always been
a role model to me ever since I was a
little kid and we've come out here
everybody on the Block everybody in the
neighborhood knows him any way he's ever
brought me to everybody knows him you
know he's just he's the men I can't I
don't know how else to put it it would
be the greatest thing that happens to a
father have his son take over or
whatever I did for so many years and
that's what I've been dishing and then I
think he's running good so I hope we'll
continue with it big shoes to fill
big shoes to fill and I'm trying to fill
them doing my best
[Music]